a new trailer to talk about that's a
time a long time ninja turtle fan all my
life growing up as you guys might know
you also might know I wasn't a huge fan
of the new movie that came out a couple
years ago however I've grown to accept
and actually enjoy the fact that kids
like it my friend and I were talking
about that you see kids walking around
the store walking around target with
their Ninja Turtle packs and their masks
and their size and they're all happy and
I'm like you know good for you kids
so these movies produced that hey I'm
glad so now we have a trailer for the
sequel so we're gonna talk about that
first of all there is fanservice galore
in here you see the turtle van you're
like holy [ __ ] the turtle van then I
thought about it I was like we haven't
seen a live-action turtleman yet now the
closest thing we had was in the first
Ninja Turtles movie April O'Neil had
this Volkswagen but that was it no
turtle van not until now
and from the moment you see the turtle
van and see it operate you see it
shooting what was it sewer lids out of
its face you know this movie's gonna be
ridiculous again for the children and I
love the fact that we're finally seeing
bebop and Rocksteady I mean even in the
old Ninja Turtles movie said toca and
Raz are and I was like they're mutants
yeah cool and I learned I mean we all
loved it but all of us when we were
children still in our heads in the
recesses of it we were like why not
bebop and rocksteady a copyright thing
doesn't matter now we have them in other
it's CGI glory a lot of CGI in this
movie that's for sure I mean this CGI
Turtles fighting CGI bebop and
rocksteady and a CGI setting shows every
Avengers movie crew and I love this is
my favorite thing about this I love the
fact that shredder is a human being you
know like he's a character
and I heard that they were bringing
shredder back and actually casting him
and you see in the trailer he actually
is a human being he's not brought to us
by KitchenAid very cool one of the best
things they could have done for this
sequel another great thing Stephen Amell
as Casey Jones when I heard hey Stephen
Amell is gonna be Casey Jones I was like
Green Arrow
totally works I'm not just saying that
because we share a birthday found that I
just recently Stephen Amell ah I guess
your birthday May I rather than the
Internet
it can't be false let's be honest Megan
Fox is still April O'Neil and although
she wasn't the worst thing about the
first movie still what is it
accomplished like what does she add to
it a Teddy shot for the trailer right
further children Tyler Perry's Baxter
Stockman's Baxter Stockman was in the
first movie also this dude who's
credited in the background is being
Baxter Stockman why don't just bring
that guy why Tyler Perry because Tyler
Perry's a bigger name so you somehow
gonna be
for me you look at Tyler power in this
movie it looks like he's acting like a
cartoon granted it's based on a cartoon
but I just hate it when that's the
excuse to act goofy I'm gonna say this
I'm gonna say it once Andre you should
have been baxter stockman and let's talk
about this is back so let's just talk
about it will arnett is back in this
movie why I have no idea why of all the
things you could have dropped him he's
not a pivotal character for the Ninja
Turtles lore yeah he's in the Ninja
Turtles lore but if he's not in it at
all it would be fine it worked for the
older movies this character wasn't and
it would work now is he gonna be a
sexual predator again is he gonna be a
creep is it gonna be a lawsuit waiting
to happen this last shot I don't even
know what to make of it but you know I
feel like I have seen this in a game
before I mean seriously this video game
101 tank busts out of the water and
there's a rhino Manning the tank and
he's shooting shells towards the screen
that you have to dodge has that not been
in a game I feel like that's been a
crash bandicoot boss or a Donkey Kong
Country boss something I has that not
been one thing in this trailer I do have
to touch on it goes against everything I
know Ninja Turtles bangs I see where
they're blatantly in the daylight like
yeah we're four brothers who hate
bullies and love this city art of
invisibility disappear without a trace
those old Splinter teachings I feel like
this trailer shows us that this movie
has what we want and it also has what we
don't want it's funny about this is that
I really I have nothing invested in this
I mean I have my Ninja Turtles movies I
enjoy the [ __ ] out of them no matter
what happens from now on I still have
those so the fact that I'm not really
like invested like oh my gosh this is a
big thing I really have nothing to do
but gain from it the movie sucks okay it
sucks I get to talk about that the
movies great awesome we have another
great Ninja Turtles movie I'll buy that
on blu-ray
I have nothing invested that's why I'm
harder on a Batman vs Superman trailer
because I'm like no I've wanted to see
Batman and Superman fight forever so
when things don't work in the trailer
more rocks on the shoulders you know I
mean if I were in Vegas and I had to put
my chips on something like bets on
something I would not put my chips on
Ninja Turtles 2 is going to be great
however I'm looking forward to seeing
what happens let's just dance so what
did you all think about the new Ninja
Turtles 2 trailer have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
[Music]